so last week I received two different
Twitter dams from people saying they
never received the prizes from a Penta
esports giveaway at first I was going to
ignore both messages because well it's
just another random social media contest
but after talking to both these guys it
turns out that some hilariously weird
[ __ ] did actually go down as in four
people didn't receive the Playstations
controller and Jerzy prizes seven months
after the contest ended Penta eSports
they have teams and League of Legends
pub G and Rainbow six siege back in
April they hosted a series of giveaways
intended to boost Penta social media
presence on Instagram they teamed up
with these two different influential
Rainbow six siege Instagram accounts pro
league material and nerfed beard the
idea of teaming up with these two
influencer accounts was that they would
also gain followers and help distribute
the prizes now these giveaways were
exactly what you'd expect people had to
follow up both influencer accounts and
Penta and then tag to friends in the
comments it's the typical [ __ ] that
clogs your timeline on a daily basis the
winners were picked and announced on
April 23rd with Playstations scuff
controllers and Penta jerseys up for
grabs and here's where common sense
falls off a cliff now meet Tim and Kyle
these are the two guys that deemed me
originally on Twitter both guys one
separate Penta giveaways and told me
they never received any of the prizes
and got ghosted by both influencers and
the verified Instagram account for Penta
both of them ended up messaging all
three accounts multiple times
nerf beard gave kiled the runaround got
aggressive and then went completely
silent according to Kyle once he
realized that something funky was going
on he reached up to other winners and
they all began calling out this [ __ ] on
Instagram since he thinks they've
essentially been scammed another winner
who reached out to me but asked that his
name not be used said that nerf beard
blocked him on Instagram after he
reached out asking about the prize that
he won nerf beard then had this weird
meltdown lashing out at the r6 community
before promptly deleting his Instagram
account with over a hundred thousand
followers I'm gonna read that meltdown
for you now alright so let's start the
siege community via
instagrams absolutely [ __ ] dreadful
full of absolute nothings with no
meaning whatsoever they all know who
they are if you've ever had the thought
yeah let's start a page in the Instagram
siege community just have a little think
to yourself and acknowledge that these
pages with few followers will do
anything in their will of competition in
order to get rid of you even making
Crusades around your page to get it
deleted or a bad reputation don't join
in I'm out and y'all pages with no
followers trying to see this is like
[ __ ] ridiculous I'm out and you're
all pages with no followers trying to
rep me try actually getting a life and
get out of your bedroom you nothing less
little Trent's catch you guys later this
page is done and if you want to keep up
with my other page you get the point so
basically this guy had a [ __ ]
meltdown and nobody's heard from him
since pro-league material on the other
hand made the account private and still
hasn't responded to anyone involved but
I reached out to pro-league material via
email and Jack bridges the owner of the
company actually responded to me here's
what he had to say our arrangement was
Penta would include one of the accounts
in the giveaway requirements so our
account would grow from the giveaway the
ps4 was to be provided by Penta but the
scuf controller was to be provided by
the other Instagram account involved
nerfed beers recently Penta reached out
to me to find the username of the ps4
winner again so they may be awarding the
winner now due to the pressure of this
story I'm unsure as to why Penta never
followed up with their promises and I'm
disappointed in their lack of
professionalism during the six months
that Tim and Kyle were waiting for
prizes that never came they messaged
multiple Penta employees including their
former social media manager and the
co-founder who allegedly ignored them
both at first I reached out to Penta and
they initially told me they were just
looking into this situation but then
later Kyle deemed me to say that Penta
emailed him and they were allegedly
sending over a belated prize and look if
Penta are now sending out the prizes
that's great but that doesn't change the
fact that they've seemingly ignored this
situation for the past six months I've
also spoken with somebody who used to
work for Penta and they agreed to chat
with me as long as they can stay
anonymous my source told me that Penta
management actively knew about this
situation while it was happening and
chose to ignore it anyway and according
to my source this is pentas mo when it
comes to
dealing with situations like this look
this isn't life or death it's just an
Instagram contest but this
back-and-forth with the winners is just
absolutely insane now in our brief
communication Penta noted that they had
no idea a nerf beard was allegedly
scamming people which all right fine but
you know what else is super easy to do
responding to contest winners who say
they've been scammed by the influencers
you've teamed up with so that's it
that's the whole story
prize winners who didn't get their
prizes missing Playstations and an
organization who seemingly doesn't give
a [ __ ] it's a funny thing that I thought
that we just want it now it's a funny
story that I thought was particularly
crazy and just wanted to share it with
you guys these guys don't [ __ ] like
Def Leppard for some reason [ __ ] you the
stereo is a great album photographs a
great song I like Def Leppard alright
it doesn't matter doesn't matter sue
move
the way that you wake up and then quit
Def Leppard on you are I don't put them
on
[Music]